go form rather yeah more short stream
method will be probably around an hour
but I felt it could be fun to join this
bullet turn and no it's a it's a somatic
kinks game hi there I also wonder if it
is I think it should be the initial
Kings gambit position yes it is so it's
not a sub variation that is like
immediately lost for anybody that is
always going to be possible with the
Kings gambit they has been this measure
Kasparov playing Nigel short in in
London quite a number of years ago and
they had to play a position from the
immortal game and Kasparov actually was
completely lost in the position that
that they had to start with and this is
of course going to be a problem if you
choose a position for such a thematic
tournament and it's essentially not
going to be a fair proposal okay I have
sacrificed the exchange and Hong Kong
compensation hmm it's not like it's not
completely clear that I have enough why
don't we have enough
yeah I'm winning the bishop simply and
again I've forgotten too just to put the
twitch chat yeah on my window this is
kind of a common mistake that I tend to
make yep
and just quickly get the twitch chat on
twitch and to get the chit on welcome to
church it says that's cool all right I
would get the children I always forget
that kind of embarrassing so back to the
tournament so yeah yeah I'm going to
take it and something like c6 should be
okay
hey it's on its own we have to you have
to be quick oh I did not want to return
the pawn that easily but okay it
happened still should be okay I think I
need a new g5 at some point somebody to
keep the material it's not bad didn't
it's an interesting kind of position I
wonder what that is got c4
yes e5s coming okay now that wasn't so
great actually I like this so much stare
threat Queen h7 oh there's a threat
Queen a5 maybe simply keeping this good
it's made
let's mate Wow whoo okay okay so I'm
going to go for the funky counter gambit
okay six I think it's best
okay doesn't look particularly
threatening and message to the
subscribers if anybody is on in fact I'm
going to take care of the emails today
so we should have somebody
soonish let's see an Knight comes to my
f3 going to get some pressure boys yeah
not so nice yeah this is okay
take this push the pawns yep probably
equal ish
I'm not sure that was a great idea it's
going to have some play yeah right
definitely shoot okay well it's a start
okay the e pawn will will go okay how
does he stop it now moving this way Oh
Kim he ran out of time you ran out of
time so are the Kings gambit I got two
blacks now right-sided advantage if you
get more blacks could be against 1,000
reading I'm going to dare to berserk
I was actually bad move
Oh
maybe should be ready ready for this it
can happen yeah and that will definitely
be made it's better with the 20
something seconds on the clock
Queen f6 rook f6 check we have seven
maid
1,000 well it's not even made what kind
of stuff is that oh I completely I
completely screwed this up I was
thinking it's made me now I'm winning
yeah but I thought it's made sorry again
some 30 points and a pretty good
opponent let's see a king's gambit
really
[Music]
looks very strange it must be good for
wider that's a good ending actually the
five is not going to happen and this is
nice now d5 maybe yeah so we went 45 but
I've got some pressure and this is a
good structure for me rope here and sky
would deform f7o this is an issue easily
cover itself let's push the pawn also
making the night look a little bit silly
no Cherie six doesn't seem to be on his
agenda so I know he does it very slow
very slow ah I know I'm the lander this
friggin hunk ah no that was bad
especially considering that this
position was extremely good at the
beginning I was I don't know with with
Evan G file-open that was very very bad
for black when I completely lost the
thread okay that's a good line action
that is a good line not sure if I played
it in a reasonable way
I simply asks how are you yeah i'm i
find enjoying the early saturday morning
mm-hmm okay morning is a bit imprecise
him already
close to noon so I have to break this
open yeah if he takes the night is going
to drop oh yeah I will play
yeah standing step make sense I will
play em I will play the us a little bit
later not for too long but I'm going to
make about one hour of streamium
so whatever it's me so I should have a
really good good game here with the
night being so offside what what's going
on here why do they play perfectly and
I'm playing badly that's bad
well what a silly game what a silly game
Wow it doesn't help that you have to
play this bad opening when I had a had a
really good position again oh don't take
too weak too slow yeah that's the
problem definitely it was silly enough
to return that's useful
maybe I'm winning this one after being
gifted huge chunks of material
it could work
maybe I'm running this Oh gives me the
Queen even enter oak it's like Christmas
what do you think about bullets never I
don't play it all that often
I sometimes sometimes do but I you
shouldn't shouldn't oh we do it yeah
thanks for subscribing Mac that's great
yeah twelve minutes to go and yeah the
two guys I lost against are leading the
tournament way and now I don't get any
game hmm give me a game
please they didn't pause right that
would be funnier waiting for a game by
your post
huh okay so um let me think about this
okay I'm going to take I don't think
that bullet is killing your chest I
think this is a bit too bit too harsh
but it's not a great idea to do it too
often definitely not
so now I have a really nice ending and
then I give away the a porn
I have a stupid I mean I'm still I'm
still okay of course because I was
completely winning before but now it
gets tricky
definitely hmm so yeah
gay porn wasn't that important
fortunately White's pawn structure was
so terrible that the blunder wasn't
wasn't essential
[Music]
okay so that was a pretty clear win why
do I only get two points
why don't only get two points for win
that's weird
really weird or did I spit a stalemate
no I won right did I stay late I'm kind
of irritated you
I know if the fire mm-hmm okay okay I am
a wretch II well I'm not I play the red
cheek well but what am I doing here
yeah great
I'm getting what fifth place in this
friggin tournament what Jesus this is
probably bad
there was a quick Oh still hurting oh my
god
oh my god at least this is going to be a
winner hope yeah okay yeah I keep also
one problem issue yeah I I do it has
some and sometimes anticipate pre moves
like logical moves let's say what they
don't happen and then then I'm losing
yeah okay was a quick win but free
svetislav is winning anyway any game I'm
so kind of shocked by those battles
losses all right come on give me g5
please yeah this is a line where black
is really better but it is so murky
anything anything can happen basically
yeah thanks for the follow ticket I will
take it if you insist
yeah I should I should preserve yeah but
I'm still in shock here that I am what I
did in this boot in this tournament
you're right I should preserve him
yeah double the cubits mmm that's a good
idea maybe I get third place at least oh
man what a disaster
I really thought I would do well with
the Kings gambit tournament because I
have some idea of course from the black
side and well yeah
with white you kind of you kind of make
it up as you go along so okay it looks
like something went wrong for white key
on d2 that cannot be healthy so
everything developed I'm two pawns up
that's good it's good I come on wow I
wanted to actually sacrifice but on e 2
this doesn't make any sense okay I mean
it's just it wasn't intended but I
actually have some compensation him
let's see what he does he takes Russia
aid I'm kind of in business
Wow people have no fear no fear
whatsoever grab everything every friggin
pawn I was lucky then was friggin lucky
yeah I'm still I'm close but I'm not
getting there yeah this end zero zero
two two zero two two this is just
nothing no points yeah I get to I get to
trying to beat the first place I mean II
DPD place this crap line I mean Justin
this is the worst part of it this is a
completely terrible line which I'm not
really refueling anyway
it's pretty uncomfortable it's very
lucky that she's not losing stuff
immediately here look f3 it's maybe just
about playable
yeah I know I can take on everyone but
I'm going to simplify it doesn't see it
rookie to blunder he doesn't see it yeah
is absolutely no tactic they let me
lower but it doesn't help them help and
I'm bow sleeping this I don't believe
this
how unlucky can you be and then he wins
on time with zero
0:04 yes here this bullet says trap
that's unbelievable unbelievable really
anyway so let's yeah there was a kind of
kind of weird right so how many points
that I actually Lucy in this friggin
channel like 50 or something anyway so
on another one there is no bullet yeah
yeah I don't play hyper bullet this is
two - no that's to make it to me but
let's play I'm going to play viewers if
you like give me some challenges so
choose yeah let's go and look for
hyperbolas
yes so I can create a tone when I keep
forgetting that it you can do that
so here this is a classical that is
called classical room with Bishop c5
it's a fairly solid line who's gonna win
today
SK or phonetic I don't follow
what are you referring to what is SK or
phonetic yes the longer time controls a
better form
for explanations and I usually don't
don't stream pull it all that much but I
saw this Kings gambit themed tournament
and I felt yes the funny one let's do it
overwatch teams hmm no yeah I know that
overwatch um is a game but no really not
really not so much knowledgeable about
new games the last game that I was
playing seriously that same was a GTA 5
so how do I get this coordinated this
Bishop is annoying rupee 8 that's nine
cheeks if five
I tried to sort this a bit like a king
here and f6 mmm
yeah I played in that title tournament
that cousin won for like 20 20 minutes
or so but my connection was absolutely
terrible so I had to stop yeah yeah if I
have played quite a bit I I played the
main storyline and most of what there
was to do and and of course I played
tons of Skyrim it's not so easy here
this position is not you need to play
even rook the aid is somehow annoying my
bishop is not well positioned I don't
know I don't play other chess variants
and actually I don't enjoy playing them
all that much position is not easy
I don't like to return power on cm maybe
I should Bishop is three and to b6 or
something the only chest variant that I
think I know that that I sometimes play
rarely but sometimes is is crazy house
try to be six yeah this is the thing
yeah my idea was to take and play rook
to b6 counter-attacking I I completely
forgot about chefs 960 and this isn't I
didn't really count that as a chance of
variant but you could probably call it
like that yes just 960 is interesting to
play I'm not I'm not enjoying it like a
lot I have to be honest there because I
think most of the positions you get are
simply an ammonia is it awkward and you
have to really work hard sometimes to to
get something that resembles a normal
chess position and I really think a
normal chess position is what you what
you should have like with some harmony
in the pieces and quite often when you
get a random position everything is
wrong with that same they have to fix it
I thought Bishop 7 was more of a chest
okay I can take threatening no it's made
very well played at the beginning by
shoes thanks for the game shoes how I
want to list what a list I guess I'm
going to start with the ones on top yes
I'm working on chasuble repertoire
Stewie for one year for repertoire is
some very very very close
very close to being finished I've worked
on it a couple of hours yesterday and I
think it's like made 195 97 percent
something like that it's just like a
little bit a little bit of work no baby
that is a very solid repertoire and easy
to learn there are no gambits no
sacrifices I mean when they are good but
not right out of the bat
did you join leeches recently um no I've
been on ditches formed quite quite a
long while and I use it on a daily basis
for mine for my lessons its own it's a
fantastic platform I've posted a video
on my youtube channel a month ago where
I outlined the ephah repertoire it will
be based on sound lines and again stuff
that is quite easy to learn let's see
how to do this 95 know maybe Queen here
it must be quite good here with the G
file G 3 would be a funny mistake who
takes G 3
okay so mm-hmm
should age three no hmm not so easy to
to play this
he's got Knight f5 lined up maybe still
this I don't know I'm not really sure
him if you have an I said porch we
exchange Queens or not in most cases in
most cases that's a that's that's not
either the same it's not either the same
in most cases you should keep material
on the board that's the majority really
of cases but you will find you will find
exceptions okay so it's their way here
to to get something going to keep this
it looks dangerous my night my night
however is pretty awful sorry I have to
get the night activated buses an idea
and try to do that Knight to f4
yeah Here I am
but now it's not made Luke age five it's
the next idea now Queen f3 you will
happen so maybe threaten Anoop takes g3
so that that worked out okay
getting the night on top so thanks for
the game simply okay going to go play
mac-10 688 let's see what I'm six it's a
bit uncommon gotcha oops yeah I'm going
to be very very direct yeah each valve
the bloomenfeld gambit yeah this is one
of the better gambits I think I have
played at the tournament chefs actually
it's some years ago admittedly but I've
played it in tournaments yes at least
some yeah Mac is going for some count to
play in the center
[Music]
age five would still be very dangerous
maybe I could have played it immediately
but then he takes on deform not so sure
about that yeah there's some pressure on
their porn on that Center Yanni CPR Nome
has played the Blumenfeld gambit a bit
in recent years there is no way to
directly punish him here think just
develop an NIT - Jeff flow
and this is the this is not the morning
coffee stream it's more like tea the tea
stream and it's a bit a bit after the
morning hours already but it's in the
spirit of the you know of the morning
coffee stream and this is black tea
actually that looks like a queen crab
yeah what areas of the game I would work
on or what areas of my game I would work
on it's a question
yeah I would work almost exclusively on
end games and calculational really not
that great in end games that depend on
calculation keeping spoiling things have
good good positions not defending the
bad position as well because I keep
making calculation errors and this is
some what would help a lot could improve
that
no a book about the budapest gambit i
would be pretty much rule out like we I
just don't think it's a particularly
great opening it stops terrible but it's
at the same time I also think it's
fairly uninteresting to be honest you
black is just going to be worse with
with any normal moves and you don't even
get any active positions I mean I don't
I don't really see the point of this
opening unless the opponent is doing
something to enlist you but you're just
going to be worse and if it does
something stupid you're not even going
to be in great shape
this is the thing like in the Blumenfeld
yeah I play something something bad and
you will give a great Center and what do
I need to play in the Budapest to be
worth with wider blunder piece maybe
okay so let's play in Vancouver style
set up here with black against arc two
row right so that's the line that is
really quite sharp and he gave me this
big center part is it possible to get a
close maneuvering position after a four
s black and well not by force but good
tries are the French defense and
something like the philidor's d65 some
good questions now
yeah moskalenko made a book on the
Budapest yeah I know that surprised me
yeah of course it's not that the
Blumenfeld gambit is a fantastic opening
if it would be everybody would play it
it has drawbacks am Bishop g5 on move
five is the is the issue but yeah I
think if you if you work on that a
little bit it's playable
I mean it's played by some good players
like Mississippi ah no play I should
have played f5 here actually would have
been better I don't think it's an
opening that I would play against strong
players that can prepare against this
that that's not probably the the
greatest IDM but the bloomfeld is
completely okay in quicker time controls
and when you surprise people or feel
they are not great at theory what about
the stone ball
yeah the stone wall is I think it's
pretty okay don't think there's a huge
issue with it I mean it's not going to
what's the point here
I just push it back
it was a bit weird 95 and just send it
back
let's get this inter check on h7 doesn't
lead to that much but still maybe it's
good to put the King on to h8 on the
other hand if I go at 5 I could be quite
happy and that they have the King on h8
for most cases and it will play a five
trying to push a form
yeah the Stonewall I think is quite okay
even theoretically speaking but it's
it's not far for everyone you have to
it's more of a strategic opening than
anything else
okay let's push
my four I have c4 Kim
now c4 I'm just taking I don't know this
maybe yeah I get everything centralized
you know I didn't I didn't take this
move into account and it makes my move
look a bit silly actually yeah yeah it
depends so you can you can of course
start with the main lines if you studied
into opening like the Banco and then
work your way to the sidelines
it's it I don't know I'm sure because
some of the sidelines I mean if you take
my repertoire them I also feature stuff
like the London system and so on and the
London for example is played it's so
often especially on the club level that
it might make sense to actually study
that quite early because you won't get
it on the board a lot and then and go
for then go for the main lines I think
in case of the Banco some of the rarer
lines you probably won't get it all yeah
a good question and garry kasparov said
that it is a good idea to study to study
and an actual or an actual board instead
of just a computer screen and I think
Kasparov is right to some extent if you
are actually playing over the board
chest I mean it could be that you only
play online anyway but if you actually
play over the watches it is it's made
right took a moment to register and if
you're actually playing an oh sorry
sorry I didn't want to really mention
too many challenges
because it's them it's a different way
of looking at the board it really is
different so I think it is quite
sensible to jump sum over the board work
I always tend to need a little bit of
time usually to adjust to or turn it
into a real board because you have so
many yeah I spent some so much time I'm
teaching online that an actual board is
is it's really different for me okay I
get I get to ruin White's pawn structure
here a bit by taking on e3 yeah the main
issue here is that this bishop is not
really great it's biting on this pawn
you know e4 is not going to be so easy
to play if I can get an f5 g5g for that
it is completely dead okay I'm going for
them my bishop also looks bad but Wow
gives me he gifts me a porn I'm going to
cast along here anyway
Oh question do you play the stock market
know what I don't I had an interest some
years ago when I was still working in
banking but I really think that it's
difficult to do if you have very limited
time and I really don't have time to
really check out things and if you don't
I think you should just don't do it
don't do single stocks it's always okay
to do you know index funds or something
but single stocks I think it's very
tricky to do so let's see if I can go
for mate
do you know where level players have to
study the opening yeah I think so it's
it's it's a rather important part of the
game I think that it's as long and it's
not like overdone I mean you shouldn't
do it exclusively but even at a lower
level you need some sort of some sort of
opening repertoire I mean it does not
have to be extremely deep and
sophisticated but it makes sense time to
study the first couple of moves and play
something that you like and be familiar
with ideas and concepts of the opening
I'm seeing really like what happens
after the first couple of moves this is
definitely going to be extremely useful
so I'm referring to yeah not just ya
know and moves by heart but but learn
actually to understand why those first
couple of moves are played in a certain
way then will also help you to
understand better the whole game because
I really don't see him a big I mean
people sometimes say yeah I'm not good
at the opening but I'm great in the
middle game as I have a third test and
this is nonsense if you're bad in the
opening yard so what's the difference if
you play crap moves you play crap moves
and the opening is is this just as
important as understanding stuff in the
middle game it's also matter of
understanding understanding things I
actually don't understand how you can be
good in the middle game and bad in the
opening it should work it shouldn't it
shouldn't sorry sorry I don't want to
rematch actually and sometimes do that
automatically so let's play sombrero
and banquette Ethan themed blitz or
repeater but yeah why not I will also do
some stimulus at a time what to do here
can I surprise him in some way the
sombrero prominent Nordea
okay so playing them the modern mainline
of the Scotch four nights one of the
many opening yeah fashions that bloody
Mike Romney has initiated he played this
aged three Queen III idea against a
Romeo
my favorite current player um I don't
really have one single player that has
support it no matter what
[Music]
as for the candidates I think if you
look at the current current form of
players probably mum Adyar off and
Aronian have the best best chances and I
would really like to see Aronian win it
he's a really it seems like a great guy
and interesting play really interesting
playing the players that are studied
most when I was improving the Karpov and
Kramnik kramnik at the time being yeah a
junior player basically or a newcomer
let same always looked at Chrome Knicks
games back when is when he was starting
mean it's like almost my age so when he
was getting to the top level I was
starting to play chess seriously
and so I looked at this a lot openings
in particular like my 93 c4 style
openings I think they come mostly from
that time now this is not much I have a
bit of pressure a bit of pressure
against the deep on
I don't think I have a particular
recommendation like what kind of puzzles
or terror of tactics should be done to
improve to a certain level it's um it's
it's it's pretty simple you have to do
it in the first place
it doesn't really matter that much like
it's not a certain kind of tactic or
yeah that you should do it's it's
comparable to physical exercise yes
sometimes people like debate yes should
I I don't know go running go swimming do
I don't know weightlifting or whatever
there is and while discussing what they
actually what they should do they forget
to actually do anything at all and this
is the same thing with tactics as long
as you do something it's going to help
and doing it is more important and doing
it regularly then what actually you are
doing yeah this is also very true for
choosing the site where you should do
the tactics you can do Lee chess you can
do no chest 24-hour chess comb or
whatever every side nowadays has a
tactics trainer and the most chest tempo
is so did I mention chess temple sister
the old old favorite let's say off of
most players you can also do tactics by
the way on on chess upon nowadays is a
pretty good tactics book on there yes
there are many many possibilities and as
long as you do it regularly it helps
probably also helps if you don't do it
so regularly but doing it at all it's
the main thing yeah instead of just I
should protect it show you and do
something and do it regularly the best
advice that I that I have especially for
people who he was public transport a lot
yeah commuting on the bus on the train
yeah do it do it while you're on
train or on the bus it's easy to do with
an app if you have a you have a
smartphone and it's going to be
extremely extremely helpful killing time
and you learn stuff thanks for the game
sombrero it was well played until you
gave me the d4 pawn and it was well
super brought down so Conan the Blitz
Troyer he's in the chat so let's go
before again did I miss Knight f5 I
wonder who cat the end maybe I was
talking too much
oh that's a gambit get problem with the
720p hmm that's surprising it's said
actually something that is influenced by
my connection or is said mostly is said
mostly at which thing I have no clue
because my connection fields rather
rather ok
hmm yeah I just recognized I should have
I should have taken note of this move
which I didn't he takes with the Queen
okay I was thinking to do sorry to take
with the pawn keep the pressure on b2
intact now I'm quite happy again with my
position made wooden wouldn't have been
bad if you're taking with the Poorman
yeah I'm already on for an hour okay I
will be on for like 10-15 minutes and
then I have to have to do some stuff
it looks a little bit dubious somehow
looks dubious 95 this night xD - maybe I
cannot refute it
no doesn't seem to be the case but this
is ok trading trading some stuff cannot
be too bad
so let's double this he actually has any
foreign know I have d5 okay
yeah I'm trying to use the pin so that
Dwight black cannot take on before as
his seven is hanging should almost
surely win the if I upon yeah he I've
got d5 Queen g6 maybe the Queen g6 and
so keeps that pawn and he's got Bishop
f3 that's a bit awkward maybe just
swooped g3 after Queen g6 I have g4
though I just recognized you know that's
probably objectively the best move he
did not have to check this I was a bit
surprised because it was a pin still
yeah congrats for winning in the club
championships drunken lawyer yeah so
take the H pawn yeah somehow we
continues him he's hanging in now
don't have a super clear win really not
maybe try to trade Queens I don't like
you or take no yeah okay I keep this for
the moment maybe edge form
yeah it's it's slightly it is slightly
uncomfortable
but Conan is not stepping up with with
this time it's not getting quicker
that's what I'm trying to say yeah I
think if you issue the challenge five
plus five that's too long let's do
something that is a bit closer to two to
blitz time control yeah I'm happy to
play a game but let's do it a bit
quicker sober you sure do do 3 plus 2 or
5 plus 0 or something like that because
I have to stop the stream soonish it
should just be like if you acted -
figures yeah like 3 plus 2 and so on it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be above 5
like 3 plus 2 4 plus 1 5 plus 0 these
these I would gladly take rupee age here
by Boresha necessary it is not necessary
to prepare no 5 plus 3 equals 8
now you have to see if here and she do
five plus three this game can easily
last that like yeah if you if you do
five plus three you can roughly
estimator if you you add the two is
eight
yeah times two sixteen this game can
last up to 15 to 16 minutes yeah I don't
have anything against this time control
five plus three five plus five but not
in a context of us dream that I feel
should be a bit quicker so that other
other players can play and I really have
to leave
soonish I actually intended to stop at
one o'clock and we above that already or
not above we have was that behind that
after that yeah this is a good move
because yeah this is this is a fork and
pancakes would have been quite awkward
strategically so yeah I have won the
exchange and now I am probably the best
strive known didn't do it 98 I was
thinking to block the deep on now I am
pushing the deep on and with them it's
past that of course you have passed that
him sometimes I really makes silly
language mistakes
yeah my idea is to get this D foul play
rolling quickly this stops noise the D
pawn is very dangerous now I have to
leave soon because I need breakfast late
breakfast that's the thing I haven't
eaten yet
yeah and the yeah I've got all the time
yeah my queen is striving for those
weakened light squares here here
typically everything is on light squares
because those are weak black is called a
dark square bishop okay who is on to
show me a three plus two and then I can
cancel can also do the quick bullet came
here let's do the quick bullet came
Muslim get quick yeah thanks for the
game gather to Shaw here we go
playing the other coins the bird opening
is not as bad as it looks meat in 147
says I actually agree I mean it's
certainly not like fantastic but there's
nothing I don't think there's some
there's anything particularly wrong with
it something like reversed Lennon garage
Dutch is probably not bad
I know that this is commonly well loved
it b6 it's commonly known as the polar
bear and this is not such a bad opening
I've had a look at this sometime oops
that's the Queen okay
will I get to I can actually try
who's who still on there Brooke could be
wanna be Wanna Sonia and it's gone I
prepared I had to prepare against a
player I'm sure like one and a half
years ago was something and this player
surprisingly played one F for quite a
lot and he had a really really excellent
score with it and I looked at the games
that was kind of interesting he was
going for mostly the reverse term
Leningrad and there's nothing
particularly wrong in plain land once in
a while it seems so we have the reversed
taraji 'm White has played for what
allowed this isolated Queen pond look
we've won a slightly mysterious as
before it's not going to be possible but
maybe you went with the name rugby one I
wanted to play would be one yeah that
would be kind of understandable
yeah okay so I'm going here and we try
to take only two and getting additional
pressure on deform I can't take you
forward
mmm it's not so clear and seven is also
hanging yeah maybe he must play would be
one in each game that would be kind of
that would be tough actually
the English opening is a good bad day
rupee one end before I came I can still
not take like I have to push him back
here first
yeah and you I know it it was an
accident accident and this small slip
okay what's going on here he's attacking
this if I take especially takes my night
this is an interesting movement a crazy
house stream against necessarily I would
love to do that I mean yes I would beat
me to shreds but it would probably be
entertaining and get it to get beat up
by one of the best crazy house players I
think yes I was pretty good at it right
so let's see
my idea is after Knight takes d4 Luke
takes c4 that the bishop and the knight
on d4 is hanging and - Bishop on h4 is
hanging the second idea is of course
irritate White Knight f5 maybe not f5 if
I take okay so I can take take this no
right
hmm isn't there some kind of discovery
doesn't look like it that's odd it's a
bit odd
yeah the Queen covered all the squares
h3e - after f5 forever I think what has
to go back yes and now let's see how to
do this if I take 25 that could be a
possibility it's very direct but I think
it's good
going for the Queen trade or if he takes
night eggs I've got an ending with a
piece up
okay with that okay thanks for the game
Ruka b1 anybody is still in the shed I
take back okay let's go I take back a
sonder I saw I have son I've seen the
Nick in the twitch chat so let's play
yeah the yessiree mode is great I really
like it
by the way it's also great to see that
many of the challenges were coming from
indeed shares supporters with the wings
like yeah I take back so yeah it's a it
means some he's a chasuble patron I
think it is called and this is great to
see that people are support the site and
actually this will make sure this it is
supported and there was the wind
we attendance that it is said developed
is what I was trying the same and
further improved yeah thanks for all the
follows yeah I take back retreats this I
won name
I wonder how to set this up I can't go
these six but G 594 is to lose I think
yeah thanks for subscribing so um g5 and
then taking it slowest though can
actually take twice take on f7 and then
check not great
how do I do the same today I do want to
change that's good therefore coming up
what's that I never the cheer thank you
jean-jacques
where was the youth there was a huge
fund I thought I have minimized small
yeah I would definitely like help with
the emotes if somebody could help me
them so King g7 I'm not sure FY it looks
really dangerous in what I take back is
doing him
really really really
yeah thanks for the Chi again my key
position is really not good
I don't like it
I really don't like it oh there's a
cheer cheering battle or something yeah
thanks for that she is
yeah his rook is trapped still bishop
chicks six things are not all that clear
you know to catch insko yeah was one of
the possibilities
I will night eggs and queen g4 check a
message okay I've got Queen g5
I was lucky though I did not see that I
did not see that at the beginning it's
an interesting 24 25 f6 check King takes
look f1 check that sucks really sucks
yeah f6 I wanted to give the key I don't
even sure that was good anyway
um there's a threat against the f7 pawn
Wow if I take on f5 this rook everyone
[Music]
oh wow
shoot very good game here behind take
back can only try to run time can you
make a draw here I he won no time
actually there was a bit difficulty I
wanted to make it drew I wanted to offer
a draw they have it there was no time
and I can is this thing sometimes yeah
my draw offer cost me the game on time
and it was there was a good game so is
anybody on that is there when a cheering
fight thank you okay let's play a couple
of more as long as you're cheering I can
play right I know my dad
I didn't do trading hours at the casual
game yeah I could have flecked of course
which I don't I really I don't know yeah
it would be good to challenge blitz
controls
yeah so I played the French exchange but
it is not that bad right
I got a slight advantage mmm
here with my is my Bishop Pam came let
me just be through me
so the cheering better was decided in
favor of San Diego of Casa thank you
now San Diego California will say and
now I get it
now I get it I'm the manner of reading
it correctly who's commentating today at
a seal
I don't know I don't know so what is
this am i a bit better here is that
equal let's have a look
somehow it feels now I can actually win
a pawn right this I check h7 King takes
Queen f5 so I felt there must be a
tactic because then we had them those
are unprotected yeah and it felt like
there's a tactic Oh immediately resigned
yeah it is very good yeah I win a pawn
and it's yes this King takes tactic
white um has them clearly better pieces
at the end so I'm going to work my way
from from the top
yeah them two nights variation here
Queenie - hey Queenie to SM is not
really great so what to do egg I forgot
what's happening here Bishop c4 I think
yeah Bishop c4 yes
how is this plating I could I come I've
completely forgotten that I think this
is what I would I would I look at ya
I've studied this for the e4 repertoire
that I'm working on but in some cases
it's been like month since I looked at
it this is this for example I I know I
know exactly when I looked at this that
was late November when I was traveling
to London and yeah it's almost small
into month my threat now is night yeah
and this is this is also good and I take
their 7 was a threat but this is this is
an issue yeah f7 is collapsing
you know I'm on this lot this has been
seen in many many games actually it has
been overlooked a lot I am invest some
pretty high-level players me no not
grandmasters but so some decent players
allowed that in a classical time control
black is basically busted now really
nothing can do against f7 collapsing so
I can take but there is nothing wrong
with inserting c3 Queen h4 maybe coming
even there's no way he's not escaping
anyway right Queen h4 D form
near Queen h4 deform the g5 Knight is
hanging some there her take on f7 c4
will be take away this is good right I
can just do this 94 Quincy form
if seven is still falling I guess you
can try Knight e4 g4 with this
counter-attack but I have g3 I think Oh
Knight g4 g 395 ha
so Knight g4 is actually saving him now
so I didn't play it right him I didn't
play it well I should have taken on f7
earlier just again he doesn't do it now
but that would have been good that would
have been good room
so I have to focus yeah that's not it's
not so easy 95 94 actually a bit
annoying take it Queen takes there's
quite some stuff hanging
93 days squeegee for check and Bishop g5
there is Queenie for check as well
yes he is
I don't see another energy for Jim
hmm yeah he could have I think 94 was
good really was good I think
and I didn't exploit his plane to the
fullest
by the way do I trap the Queen here
g4 like Queen h5g for this Queen age
three it's the only is the only square
okay but by now it was under control
again but it wasn't before
yeah thanks for the game Arturo sulukule
it must be an older challenge I already
have to stop and eat something
hey getting very hungry by now this is
not just like a stupid stupid trick or
anything I think this is an interesting
line Queen gets activated
yeah see you soon mate in 47 you so d 5
coming up on IG for legal let's take
some time d5 I think is the main idea
that's a bit awkward I might win a pawn
yeah I mean I win a pawn I can take you
I can take okay thanks for the game
legal well so couple of guys I already
played rugby one high wind high wind
fantasies I think I played Tsubasa
I didn't play so let's played Tsubasa
and yeah I'm making this the final game
I really have to get some food into my
system Tsubasa so playing this extremely
close opening the chickpea noni well
sometimes Condor which Benoni I think
yeah I'm not too unhappy about that I
get to trade this potentially
problematic
you sure so my idea here is to go f5 and
I can do it right now but not sure
okay Sufi super I'm sorry I cannot I'm
probably mispronouncing this terribly
what is your name they have no I'm in
one game I can go I can go for what I'm
not seeing it I don't see your name this
is not looking good
I don't think I've displayed that quite
a bit
trying for b5 a high wind filters okay
then we play the form I was thinking we
played in the stream yeah actually
but probably I'm wrong then yes
now g5 was really yeah on the cards okay
so I'm not not happy here but still
don't take a moment until my king
position opens up yeah at Tsubasa is
doing it right he plays it correctly the
way it should be played
what a bad position
oh when is that here 3 minute yeah okay
I get a night too if I have at least 96
hangs huh okay hello I don't mind
yes Knight f3 stuff and there c3 I want
to go see 3 he actually try to get 94 in
the game
okay the Queen could take 9a four of
them yeah let's do it
mighty fine so that I have looked before
coming I know what g7 is hanging and
maybe this is already like fades out of
it I want some kind of play even if it's
not objectively working group c4 is the
threat it's not clear at all I have
given a full rook but Jake so chick
there 93 maybe on how to do it
93 and c4 may be attending Queen Dido if
I cook Wendy - Queen B -
you can take it okay
yes I'm always happy to discuss a stream
a match that's a good move
yes correctly and says that I'm not
threatening much
dodging bullets unsuccessfully probably
but Luke g7 King f6 might be okay he has
no check 95 is the problem I think that
is probably winning that could also win
my head wins so can be irritating here
chick chick chick chick and a long time
again and this is crazy I never get my
rating to anything yeah yeah that's
crazy
ah my goodness umm my goodness
okay so high wind finders is it that's
the final one I have to I have to quit
after that I yes to do something simple
develop pieces
yeah just for go for very simple opening
him shouldn't be too bad
they've got defy them it's probably not
bad d5 that looks if he goes d5 had
looks a lot like a French exchange and
probably it's something that black
should do bishop aged seven nine takes
Bishop e7 s rupee aid but now I'm
threatening it Bishop takes an age seven
okay
mm it's actually probably not bad to
simply trade because of the time game
Jen I'm gaining lots of time 9 g5
threatens not much but still probably
interesting for rookie 8 stuff warm
tactics involving the back rank this is
somebody an issue with the Age pawn
missing black cannot really get rid of
the night yeah I'm just rupees seven
maybe ok I'm going to be very lazy here
with a three
yeah just improve this position a little
bit the traders is nice I mean it's a
pawn and I have fun the better better
pieces as well
knight Knight to e4 maybe coming okay
yeah this is also an option that I was
considering let's do it
[Music]
h3g for me pushing the Queen back reform
and the Queen has no squares actually
this is a fun Queen trap it has no
squares for him absolutely no squares
can maybe save it with 94 No maybe
preparing Luke H 1 and that's trapped
again yeah no for real yeah thanks for
the game zippy
ok so thanks a lot for watching guys
that was an unplanned stream a bit
longer they know originally you wanted
just wanted to go for now I know we're
close to two yeah thanks a lot for
watching
hmm I will be on soonish certainly
Monday evening and yeah tomorrow I will
do something that is not only chess
actually I would do a stream on the
ICC's YouTube channel it's a live stream
at 9 p.m. Central European Time in the
evening about the final three rounds of
town still tomorrow evening yeah I would
post something on my youtube channel as
well to announce that thanks all for
watching bye bye